à saint marcel dans la proche
agglomération de chalon sur saône
l'entrée en vigueur des mesures
sanitaires renforcés samedi matin n'a
pas été une surprise dans ce café
restaurant frappé de plein fouet par la
fermeture obligatoire des débits de
boissons à partir de 22h m'attendais à
ce que ça soit moins rapide et je
pensais que les centres des villes un
peu plus petits comme chalon serait
peut-être pas toucher aussi fortement
ça fait peur parce que on se dit est ce
que noël va être préservée ou pas et est
ce que notre activité va survivre à tout
ça pas de changement pour le restaurant
ouvert seulement à midi mais le
cuisinier d'origine italienne s'inquiète
lui pour les soirées de foot devant la
télévision au bistrot qui vont forcément
être raccourcies la semaine prochaine
pour les prochaines quatre semaines en
plus il ya la champion's league et là
les matchs de foot et tout d'un coup les
clients qui vont venir pouvoir match nul
à 22h on ne peut pas regarder le match
sur la première mi temps
j'aime quand ils vont rentrer à la
maison face à la progression du nombre
des cas de kobe de 19 la municipalité a
réagi en amont des nouvelles mesures
sanitaires pour éviter les regroupements
nous avions nous déjà ça marcel interdit
la location des salles municipales aux
particuliers nous les avions simplement
dédié aux associations pour leur
assemblée générale
donc nous allons poursuivre de la même
manière les
vite sont respectés à savoir celle et de
fait le port du masque obligatoire les
mesures de distanciation physiques sont
devenues habituelles à chalon ce
restaurateur a constaté que les clients
ils sont très attentifs
c'est plus rassurant oui parce que
maintenant je pense que le nombre est
passé dans une phase que les gens sont
plus conscients du coc vide
est ce que ça peut engendrer dans de
futurs 6es pas respecté les mesures
sanitaires renforcés s'applique en saône
et loire jusqu'au 15 novembre